When I feel depressed,
like
I say,
I feel down,
right?
As I was learning about the causes of
depression,
anxiety,
if I bit lost connections,
I started to realize,
I don't think that's the metaphor.
This is amazing.
Um,
professor at Stanford called Robert
Sapolsky,
who in his early twenties went to live
with a troop of baboons in Kenya,
and it was his job to figure out when
are baboons most stressed out.
So his job was to hit them with little
tranquilizer darts and then take a blood
test and measure something called
Cortisol,
which is a hormone that Bobbins and ours
released when we're stressed.
And baboons live in this hierarchy,
so the females don't interestingly,
but the men live in a very strict
hierarchy.
So if there's 30 men,
number one notice above number two,
and I've been tuned noses above number
three,
number 12 notices by number 13.
And that really determines a lot of the
Tennessee you get to have sex with.
It determines what you get to eat.
It determines whether you get to sit in
the shade or pushed out into the heat.
Yeah,
it's a really,
really significant way you are in the,
in the hierarchy and what professors are
polsky found is I've been to,
are most stressed in two situations.
One is when their status is insecure.
So if you're the top guy and someone's
circling,
which comes for Ya,
uh,
you will be massively stressed.
And the other situation is when you feel
you're at the bottom of a hierarchy,
your,
you know,
you've been kind of humiliated.
And what,
what professor Sir Pasky found,
which I think is really noticed and then
it was later developed by other
scientists is when you feel you've been
pushed to the bottom,
what you do is you show something called
it submission gesture.
So you baboons will raise a,
as I say,
you,
I seem assume by means of watching this,
maybe they are you a Babin will put its
body down physically or put its head
down.
It will put its bottom in the air and it
will cover its head.
So it's clearly seems to be
communicating,
just leave me alone.
You've beaten me.
Okay,
you've beaten me.
And what lots of scientists or
subsequent about people like professor
Paul Gilbert in Britain and Professor
Kate Pickett and professor Richard
Wilkinson also in Britain,
have really developed as this idea that
actually what human depression is in
part,
not entirely,
but in part is a form of a submission
gesture.
It's a way of saying,
I can't cope with this anymore.
Right.
Particularly people who feel they've
been pushed to the bottom of hierarchies
or he feel,
remember the other stressful situations
when you feel your status is insecure,
it's a way of just going,
okay,
I retreat.
I don't want this fight anymore.
You'd beaten me.
It's,
it's a kind of very strong evolutionary
impulse where you feel you're under
attack to just submit in the hope that
the stress and anxiety will then go away
and that the sources of the stress and
anxiety will then go away.
And one thing,
so pondering cable,
consider,
sorry.
Kate Pickett in Richard Wilkinson really
developed this is,
they've shown so and I was,
an inequality grows,
um,
depression and anxiety grow.
They've shown this very robust effect,
right?
This helps us to explain it.
If you live Norway,
you're status is relatively secure,
right?
No one's that high.
No one's that low.
Um,
movement between where you are is not so
extreme.
If you live in the United States,
especially today,
which is we're now at the greatest
levels of inequality since the 1920s
there's a few people at the very top.
There's a kind of precarious middle,
and there's a huge and swelling bottom,
right?
So you've got,
you can see why in the United States
you've got more people who'd be showing
a submission gesture,
who'd be like,
oh,
Jesus,
I'm,
I've been beaten than they would be in
Norway.
This is why inequality is one of the
drivers of depression and anxiety and
why dealing with inequality reduces
inequality and anxiety.
It's one of the things that really
shocked me actually,
it was looking at,
in the United States,
the group with the lowest depression by
far as the amish.
So I went and spent time with an amish
community.
The Amish live in these homogenous
groups,
which are incredibly equal.
The richest amish is as worth as much as
the poorest amish,
right?
They're not showing sub submission
gestures in the same way cause nope,
they don't fit.
There's a lot wrong with the amish.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not suggesting mass conversion to
the Amish.
I'm a gay man.
Believe me,
I'm not.
But,
but we,
we can learn from the fact that in these
highly equal and homogenous groups,
you don't have that,
that extreme status stress.
Now,
I don't want to go as far as the amish
deep,
but we moving closer to it would be one
of the factors that would reduce
depression and anxiety.
Yeah.